hi i'm ria welcome back to make it fancy
let's see what i'm making fancy today hi
brie it's jana and i am challenging you
to make jollibee fancy jollibee was the
first filipino fast food restaurant that
i've ever been to and they're killing it
i especially love the chicken joy i
can't wait to see what you come up with
and good luck really
jollibee
i love jollibee this is my favorite fast
food restaurant honestly i don't think
jollibee needs any improvement but this
is making fancy chicken joy
comes with fried chicken gravy and white
rice i was invited to a party my friend
draw like hundreds of jollibee chicken
baskets and that was my first time to
meet jolie b the skin is crispy and
chicken is so juicy
it's so good
and so tender just being asian having
rice with
fried chicken makes sense to me chicken
joy is already
a perfect meal so i have to make
something
very unexpected and surprising i'm
excited to make it fancy
alright here's what i got scallions
chives celery king trumpet mushroom napa
cabbage shallots ground pork ginger and
garlic from the pantry i got peanut oil
canola oil olive oil sesame oil flour
white vinegar salt five spice powder
sichuan chili flakes sichuan peppercorn
toasted sesame seeds jantang gum soy
sauce and sake alright let's get started
make it fancy
first ingredients chicken joy keep some
little surgery separate
chicken skin easily comes off separate
meat from the bone i like style better
flavor lights but i feel like if you
order breast comes with more food it's
life hack put
chicken bones one shallot one stark
celery and ginger slices three cloves of
garlic two cups of water into pressure
cooker one pinch of salt cook this for
60 minutes
wait how does this look
60 minutes later my stock is ready
smells good and i'm going to strain i
want to taste it
needs much more salt i made a delicious
jollibee broth and i'm gonna set it
aside and move on to next step two cups
of oil one minced shallot five cloves of
minced garlic two tablespoons of
szechuan peppercorn for those who never
had sichuan peppercorn it kind of
tingles your
tongue and lips it's really fun flavor
and sensation cook this in low and slow
about 15 minutes until the temperature
goes 215 degrees and shallow is a little
bit crisp up but not too brown it has
been cooking about 15 minutes and i'm
going to use the skin i removed earlier
chop kind of same size as the shallow i
made a video about beads for tasty i
went to somebody's backyard and he was
making honey so i i know one or two
things about bees
jollibee
has a girlfriend is she butterfly
you add this into the oil cook another
15 minutes until shallow is crispy and
golden i have sichuan pepper
3 4 cup of chili flake one and a half
teaspoon of five spice powder
one teaspoon of salt and i'm going to
pour over mix well let it sit at least
30 minutes i'm going to use all right
skim in the chicken joy box add 2 tbsp
of water pulse
until like a paste texture scrape on the
side and i'm going to add water as
needed
out in the bowl this looks good but this
still needs more ingredients i have 120
gram of flour add 60 grams of the rice
paste i made 3 4 teaspoon of zantangam
and zantangam is kind of additive it
helps
hold the shape together four tablespoons
of water
2 tsp of olive oil mix everything
together
and once it started coming together i'm
going to knead by hand use a little bit
bench flour
jolibee rice dough is a little bit rough
because you know even we processing the
food processor there it's like a little
bit grain rice i think it's still pretty
good
taste would be nice because rice is a
little sweet but we will see so i'm
going to knead until the dough is a
little bit smoother on the surface i
think this is good almost like a pasta
dough it is a little bit smooth and
bouncy put it in the bowl covered with
plastic and rest for 30 minutes so i
have fried chicken meat i'm going to
mince
1987 1978 put
chicken in a bowl half pound of ground
pork one cup of chopped napa cabbage
half cup of king trumpet mushroom
quarter cup of chives two tablespoons
gravy one tablespoon of soy sauce half
tablespoon of sesame oil grate
two cloves of garlic grate a half
teaspoon of ginger one tablespoon of
sake mix everything with using my hand
just make sure everything combines well
i think filling is ready but i have more
stuff to do i have the dough i've been
resting sprinkle some flour on the
surface roll this out the one long log
i'm going to cut this i'm cutting
them into pieces roll it out into
circuit board you have to do it from the
side because the center should be a
little bit thicker than the edge because
you're folding i think though it's
actually
working pretty good covered with plastic
while i'm working on other adults so it
doesn't
dry out you want to make about four to
five inches on sako it's not like making
cookie if you rolling at once outside
it's getting a little bit thicker so you
want to make it outside it's thinner
than the center alright it's time to get
fancy
[Music]
i made dumplings let's
fry them up one tablespoon of oil put
this
in a pan
heat up the pan over medium high heat
sear the dumpling until it has a nice
brown color on the bottom cook them in
batches because i don't want to crowd
the pan after you get nice brown color
on the bottom add three tablespoons of
jollibee broth and cook dumplings about
five minutes or until inside is
completely cooked all the chicken stock
is evaporated though it looks a little
bit baked i think it's ready transfer to
the tray and i'm going to cook the rest
i made a dumpling filling with jollibee
fried chicken's meat
and gravy i made dumpling wrapper using
jelly beans rice chili oil using jelly
beans fried chicken crispy skin let's
play it's nice and crispy
or chili oil
and some sesame seeds garnish and we are
done
[Music]
jollibee dumpling with chili oil very
fancy
welcome jana to make you fancy thank you
oh my god this is like a dream being on
here
so i'm so happy you challenged me and i
made dumpty is this real
i mean not surprised that you would make
this fancy but i did not expect
dumplings cheers
[Music]
this is jolly bee mhm
i didn't know jollibee could be this
fancy
filipinos are our firm believer of the
jolly bee supremacy it's so cool that
you were able to take jollibee and make
it into something completely different
and new and exciting it's like a perfect
like fusion of of two cultures we could
take some notes
so jana did i make jollibee chicken joy
fancy
a thousand percent fancy thousand
persons
by the way i love this make it fancy
merch thank you you can get it
shopmakingfancy.com
oh there's even a website okay all right
we have one last things to do it's the
dance yes three two one make it faster
make it fuzzy
[Music]
you